IL-SUNG LEE: Hi, everyone.
My name is Il-Sung Lee,
and I'm a product manager
within the Google Cloud
working on a key management
and encryption.
Along with me, I have my
colleague, Joseph Valente,
who is a product manager for
the Key Access Justification.
And we're here to talk to
you about the new world
of controlling your data in
the cloud with EKM and KAJ.
So in this session today
we're going to talk about some
of innovations in the
Google Cloud Platform
that's going to
help you really have
tight control over
your data on the Cloud
to an unprecedented degree.
And by the end of
this presentation,
you'll understand
how the system works
and how it's going
to benefit you.
And hopefully some of you will
actually give it a try as well,
and understand how
you can actually
use it to protect your
most sensitive data.
So in this talk, we'll have
three primary sections.
First, we'll talk about the
current encryption that's
in GCP.
And then followed by a
more in-depth discussion
around Cloud
External Key Manager.
And then after
that, I'll turn over
to Joseph, who's going to talk
a little more about the Key
Access Justification
product with you.
To start off with, let's talk
about the current encryption
in GCP.
And usually I like to start
off with this the scale that
finds a control of the keys
and the products that we
have available.
On the left hand side, we have
the situation where Google
has complete control over the
keys, and the right hand side,
it's a situation
where the customer
has control of the keys.
So to start off on
the left hand side,
we're talking about
default encryption.
And this is basically
Google's capability
of encrypting all your data
at rest, whatever it is
and whichever service.
So whenever you bring
data up into our Cloud
it's always
encrypted, and there's
no way to turn that off.
And Google was the
first cloud to do this.
And then for people who need
a little bit more control,
we introduced Cloud KMS.
And Cloud KMS provides
a global service
that provides management
for your software keys,
and Cloud KMS performs
two primary services.
One, it'll allow you to actually
do encryption, decryption,
and signing for
whatever blossom data
that you provide through
our easy to use rest API.
And two, it allows you to
integrate with other services,
such as BigQuery, GCE, GCS,
Cloud Sequel, et cetera,
that allows you to
take the data that's
encrypting those
services and ultimately
control it through a key that
you control in Cloud KMS.
Now besides that,
we have Cloud HSM,
which is basically the
hardware version of Cloud KMS.
And in cloud HSM,
you can actually
create keys and perform
all crypto-operations
within the fleet of HSMs
that Google maintains.
And these HSMs are all fixed
140-2 level three devices.
One of the nice properties
about putting keys in HSM
is that the hardware
will actually
make sure that the key
material is never exposed,
including to Google itself.
Next to that we have
customer-supplied encryption
keys, which is one of
our first technologies
for key management.
It was tailor made
for GCS and GCE.
Essentially, in this
situation the data-at-rest
is protected by a key
that the application
has to provide
every time it tries
to access the data itself.
Now it's fairly
limited, and you also
have to come to
terms with the fact
that the application
has to perform
some of the key management, and
also has access to the keys.
And it probably won't be
expanded beyond GCS and GCE
for those reasons.
And finally, we
have a new entry,
which is a private host HSM.
And this is an offering by
which if you have your own HSM
device that you
would like Google
to host in a colo as nearby
one of our data centers,
because you have workloads
for example, life and shift
workloads, then this is
available for select customers.
And it's something that
you can talk to me,
or talk to one of
our sales reps,
and get more information about.
But even with those
offerings we're
still left with
the problem, how do
I retain possession and
control over my keys
while I'm still trying to
take advantage of the Cloud
for processing and
storage of my data itself?
So you have the Cloud with
all its immense computing
capabilities and
scale, but you still
want to have that tight
control over the data
itself through
control over the keys.
What do you do?
So wouldn't it be
nice if you actually
had something beyond
the five offerings
that we have listed here?
Or something that perhaps goes
to the far right of this scale.
And that's where a Cloud
External Key Manager fits in.
The service is now
available as GA
in all regions around the
world, including multi-regions.
And the service
is the first time
that a cloud is able to allow
you to separate your data fully
from your keys, and allow you
to essentially externalize
your keys outside the Cloud.
Some people, including
analysts, are calling this hold
your own key, compared
to bring your own keys.
But essentially, it's that.
And so if we start talking
a little more about Cloud
External Key Manager,
you'll come to see quickly
what I'm talking about.
But before we go into that,
let's backtrack a little bit.
And I want to talk a little
bit about Customer Management
Encryption Keys, and how the
keys hierarchy is essentially
set up.
So in this jargon here
you'll see the fact
that when you bring data
up into the Cloud, let's
say it's a GCS object.
What we'll do first of all, so
take that object most pleasant
to separate chunks.
OK.
We'll take into
manageable chunks,
and each of those chunks will
have its own individual key
generated for its AS key.
And once the key
is generated, it
will encrypt that piece of
data, and these chunks of data
will be replicated.
And then basically distributed
across all the servers
within our data centers.
Now you can obviously
put that key
right next to the data itself.
You need to actually make
sure that key's protected.
So you encrypt it or wrap
it using some other key.
So you encrypted with a key
encryption key, so to speak.
And typically what
customers will do
is that they will
use a key that's
in our Cloud KMS, Cloud HSN, to
actually be the key encryption
key for that data
they have in GCS,
or a number of different
services as well.
Now in the Cloud
External Key Manager
we have a situation where
you follow the same pattern,
except instead of protecting
with a key encryption
key that's in our KMS or
HSN, that key actually
resides outside.
And so if you see
the diagram here,
a user can actually
go in and either
put their data through in
BigQuery and Compute Engine.
Or if they want to actually
direct encrypt the data
through a symmetric
key that's external,
they can do that as well.
And these services communicate
directly with our KMS.
Our KMS recognizes the fact that
these keys are not internal.
That they're external.
And then parlays request
alter our Cloud EKM,
which then communicates with
the External Key Manager.
And so in the example I
gave earlier with GCS,
the data encryption key
is sent to KMS or HSN
to actually do encryption,
decryption, wrap, and unwrap.
In this example, the
data encryption keys
will be sent to the
External Key Manager, which
would do the wrap and unwrap.
And send it back to us
through a secure channel.
Now the key point here
is that that external key
that's doing the wrap and
unwrap is always outside.
It's strictly outside of Google.
And Google does not have a copy
or access to that key itself.
So as you can see,
there's a clear boundary
now between the
data and the keys
themselves, which provides
you with that ideal security
separation.
Now in terms of the
integrators that
have support for Cloud EKM,
there's five currently.
Half of them are cloud
services, and other half
are providing
infrastructure services.
So in terms of cloud services,
Equinix, Ionic, and Thales.
They all provide cloud services.
So you can sign up using their
web portal, create a key,
and it's basically a key
that they'll manage for you
in the Cloud.
And then another half are
providing things like HSNs.
So for Fortanix and
Thales both provide HSMs
that you can host in your own
data center, or on premise.
And Unbound sells
software that you
install into your
own servers, and you
perform multipart computation.
But then the question becomes,
why would I go through this?
And what are the real benefits
of External Key Manager,
if they're not obvious already?
So number one,
maintain key provenance
comes to mind right away.
And what I mean by that is that
you'll have a situation now
where you, as the person who
owns the actual External Key
Manager, will have
really, really
strong and tight
knowledge around where
the key was generated,
where it's kept,
who has access, who made a copy.
And you'll have your own
set of auto-logs that
keep track of all the usages.
And these are all things that
would make your compliance
regulator very happy, and
make it very easy articulate
to them where the
key is in the fact
that you have ownership of it.
To access control is
another really big motivator
for people to use Cloud EKM.
So as I've been explaining
in the previous slides,
the key is to actually
decrypted the data
arrest are always outside.
OK?
So from that perspective, if
that key was ever withheld,
then there's no path by
which Google can actually
go and decrypt the data.
So once data is at arrest,
it would stay arrest.
Effective becomes crypto
shredded at that point,
until the external key
is made available again.
And then the third reason is
centralized key management.
And so in many cases,
there are situations
where a customer
may want to have
one centralized key
manager where they
implement one set
of policies for all
the keys in their company.
And this may include
keys are in the Cloud,
in other clouds on Premise.
And this gives you
a really nice way
of actually managing and keeping
the keys all in one place.
And so hybrid cloud, multi
cloud, single policy.
these are all reasons why you
may want to use Cloud EKM.
Now in terms of configuring
the service, it's very easy.
So in the diagram that you
see on the right hand side,
this is just basically basically
our UI for creating a key.
So typically you've
seen the fact
that you can generate a key.
You can import a key.
But now you'll see that there's
an external manage key radio
button.
If you select that,
then what happens
is that once you create
the key externally,
you'll be given a URI.
That will basically
define that key,
and then you come to our
dashboard, or our UI,
and select externally
managed key.
And then you enter at the
very bottom of that page,
you can see the key URI field.
You put that in there.
You create, and for that
point forward, we'll
validate that the key
exists externally.
And then from that
point forward, the key
will show up as if it's
any other key within KMS,
Now it'll look identical,
except for the fact
that if you list the keys
out under protection level,
it will say external rather
than software or hardware.
A couple other things
you point out about this.
This is only available
currently for symmetric keys.
And again, it's something that
is available in all regions.
So that's a nice thing.
Now there's a few
considerations I
like you to take away when
you actually use this as well.
First of all, these
things are outside
of Google infrastructure.
So as a result, there's
additional points
of failure there introduced
as a result of this.
And if it's a situation
where this is really
a big concern for you.
Where you need to
have something that
has a high degree
of availability,
a high degree of performance,
low latency, all that stuff.
And you want to make sure
that's something that has
called Cloud Skill for example.
Then it may be
something that's worth
considering to use Cloud
KMS, or Cloud HSM instead.
In general, I actually
usually recommend
to my customers to think of
things very holistically.
That when you have
data then you should
be able to categorize data
in terms of at least the most
critical, the high importance,
and maybe less importance.
And based on that,
that whould drive
the type of key
management selection
that you make with
EKM perhaps being used
for your most critical data.
Now errors that come from
the External Key Manager,
for example, there's
a network error,
or the External Key Manager is
turned off for whatever reason.
Then these are all going to be
manifested when you actually
try to use the key itself.
You'll get very
clear errors that
say that the key manager
is not accessible,
the keys been disabled,
things like that.
And the errors themselves
will show up as user errors.
And they will show
up through directly
through the error message.
And they will also
be logged as well.
So if you turn on
data access logging,
you'll see them in your logs.
Now there's only one
URI per key as you
saw in the previous slide.
And the implication
of that is that you
need to be in control of the
availability of the External
Key Manager yourself.
And so in that
case, you may have
to do something
like leverage VIPs,
or leverage things like
load balancers on your side,
to make sure that you have
a properly available system
that's making your keys
available for your production
workloads.
And please, work very closely
with your extreme key manager
provider as they should be able
to provide you with guidance
around the best approach in
terms of choosing locations,
how to set up your
system to make sure
that's highly available.
Now I'd like to show you a quick
demo of how we use our Cloud
EKM together with Ionic to
protect data and BigQuery.
And so in this demo
you'll see real quickly
how powerful Cloud EKM
can be in protecting
your data in the Cloud.
So the first thing
that we're going to do
is create a new key.
And so as I explained before,
you have three options.
You can use a
generated key, meaning
that the Q be created by
Google, either in our Cloud HSM
or Cloud KMS service.
Or you can actually
use key import
so that you can provide
your own key material.
Or the third one is
externally managed key, which
is what we're interested in.
And to select a
sterling match key
and you can give it
any name that you like.
And as you can see, the
purpose and the key type
are greyed out,
because the only type
of key that Cloud EKM
supports at the moment
are our symmetric keys.
So at the very bottom, there's
a field called the key URI.
And this is the only other
thing that you have to provide.
When you create the key
index External Key Manager,
they'll provide you
with this URI, which
uniquely identifies a key.
And in this case, I've already
created a key in Ionic machine.
And so I'm just going to paste
in here, and then hit create.
So just like that the
key's been created.
And what's happened
underneath the covers
is that not only have
we cataloged that key
within our Cloud KMS,
but we've actually
gone through and validated and
tested that key to make sure
that it exists.
So now I'm going move
over to BigQuery.
So you can easily go
and create your own data
set or your table.
And you can associate
it with that key
by simply going to
advanced options,
saying custom manage key,
and then choosing your key.
If it doesn't show
up, you can just
simply enter the key ID directly
and just put it in here.
But I've already done
this to save some time.
And as you can see
here, when I actually
run the results comes back.
It's nothing really interesting.
But this data in order to be
able to be decrypted and then
the query run, actually
went externally
to Ionic to get the data
encryption key decrypted.
And they came back so that
we can decrypt the data
and show you the results set.
Now to prove that this is
actually what happened,
I'm going to go to
Ionic's dashboard.
And I'm going to disable this
key just I have associate
with the BigQuery data set.
So now that that's been disabled
let me go back to BigQuery
and try running that
exact same query again.
And so you can see that we
return to error right away,
and the error message says
external key provider message.
So the message came directly
from the EKM that state
that the operation was denied.
And so this is
basically a message
that's coming directly from the
External Key Manager stating
that the key was denied.
And therefore, because we
couldn't use external key
to actually unwrap the
data encryption key,
and therefore, we couldn't
actually run the query.
So from our perspective,
from Google's perspective,
the data is no
longer accessible.
Now to re-enable that
all we simply have to do
is just re-enable
this key policy.
And it's over right now.
And I go back, and I hit run
for the same query again.
And now the data
is available again.
So this is sort of a
quick demonstration
to show how tightly linked the
ability to actually decrypt
the data and run the query is
to the key that's external.
So now that you see how
easy and powerful using
Cloud EKM is with BigQuery.
And it is the same
with GCE as well.
I'd like to turn it
over Joseph, who's
going to talk about key
access justification,
and you'll see how
the two together
will take it to the next
level in terms of control
of raw data on the Cloud.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks, Il-Sung.
As Il-Sung mentioned,
I'm Joseph Valente,
the product manager for
key access justification
here at Google Cloud.
And I'm really excited to talk
to you about this new product,
and why we think it's
a huge innovation.
I'm going to give an overview
of how this product works,
and hopefully talk
through why it's
such a huge benefit
to you if you're
using Excel Key Manager on GCP.
And as part of
this walk through,
I want you to
imagine that you're
a person who's
using a query today,
and you're just using the
standard day forward encryption
with Google.
And you go ahead
and run a query.
And the BigQuery software
needs to decrypt your data,
because it's
encrypted by default.
And so it's going
to go ahead and call
our internal key
management system
and say, please decrypt
this data for me
so I can run the query.
The internal key
management system
will go ahead and
authorize that decryption.
The BigQuery software
will perform the query,
and then we're done.
If you want more control
though over this process,
you may want to instead
of using the default
encryption, as Il-Sung discussed
earlier in the presentation,
have more control by
using our Cloud KMS
service, or our Cloud
key management service.
This key management
service allows you
to control the keys yourself.
And if you delete
one of these keys,
then there's no longer any
ability for the service
to access your data.
Even when you're using
this, though there
remains two pathways
that are often of concern
to customers who are
using the absolute most
sensitive operations on GCP.
And those are the
administrators who are still
needing to run the
BigQuery software,
as well as the key
management service,
we obviously lock down
administrative access
very, very, very tightly.
There's only a very
small number of people
who are able to exercise
administrative privileges.
The things that they can
do are very, very limited.
You can also use tools
like our apps approval tool
to put yourself in the
approval loop for these kinds
of administrative operations.
But the concern that is in the
most very, very sensitive cases
is often too much for people.
And so they would prefer to
not have the concern at all.
And that's where our
External Key Management
service comes in.
Once you use the cloud
External Key Manager
service to host your keys,
our key manager administrators
no longer have access to
the key encryption key,
as Il-Sung was
discussing before,
which is now living inside your
External Key Manager service.
Obviously, that comes
with a set of trade offs.
You need to continue
working with your partner
to manage the
availability of this key,
and to make sure
that you're meeting
your goals in that space.
But the trade off in
some limited cases
is obviously worthwhile
for these operations.
And so if you're using
the key managed service,
you get this benefit.
But there's one
piece missing, which
is that requests coming into the
External Key Manager service.
And you need to
still have visibility
over why those are happening.
They can happen
for three reasons.
You are running a query,
the BigQuery software itself
is performing some operation,
like it's doing a compression,
or a data optimization so that
you can run your queries more
efficiently later, or there's
some administrative operation
happening.
So you've opened up for
example, a ticket with Google.
And you said, I'm experiencing
some performance issues,
and I need you to go ahead
and take a look at something
and tell me what's going on.
And what key access
justifications gives you is it
gives you visibility over
each of these reasons
through a justification
that comes
through with every request that
is made to your External Key
Manager service.
What we're now
going to say is how
you can use blocking
policy on these requests.
When each request
comes through you
can set a policy at your
External Key Manager
that contains any combination of
so allow denials that you want.
You can say, for example,
block all access,
and the key will become
completely unavailable.
And Google will have no
access to data whatsoever.
You can block just
the administrator
rows that are the four green
rows at the bottom here.
And that will stop
Google administrators
from having access to your
data even though you'll still
be able to continue using
customer initiated or system
operations to continue
to using the service.
And what this gives
you is the ability
to become the ultimate arbiter
of access to your data.
You are the person who is
the ultimate decider of when
your data can be accessed,
and for what reason
it can be accessed.
So what we're excited
to announce today
is that key access
justifications is now
in beta for Google
Compute Engine, Persistent
Disk, and BigQuery covering the
transition from data at rest
to data in use.
And the exciting part
about the software
is that when you use it together
with External Key Manager
you can become the ultimate
arbiter of access to your data.
And this works together with
the integrity commitments
that are contained in our
privacy website as well.
So you know that
Google doesn't have
any kind of backdoor access,
or other ways of getting access
to your data.
It really works the
way it's described.
We need to come to you and
query your External Key
Manager to decrypt your
data, and we give you
a reason when the
decryption happens
that you can use to determine
whether or not grant us access.
What does this mean for you?
You become the ultimate
arbiter of access to your data.
No other cloud provider
is offering you
this level of control.
Your keys are going
to live outside Google
with no administrative
access, and you'll
have visibility
over what those keys
you access with
the ability to deny
Google's access for any reason.
So the fine print, can
you turn this on yourself?
Not right now.
We have a blog post
that you can head to,
which has a link on it where
you can express your interest.
And we'll be in touch
with you, and consider
whether you're eligible
based on variety of criteria.
You will need to use
Google's External Key Manager
product to use key
access justifications.
For the reasons we've
described, obviously
the great benefit
comes from having
the keys outside of Google.
And so yes, while there
are awesome trade that
are involved in choosing whether
you use External Key Manager,
we think that for those very,
very sensitive operations,
those are the ones
where you're going
to want to consider using key
access justifications as well.
So what data is in scope for
key access justifications?
Generally speaking, it's
the high sensitivity data.
So you can think about it as
things like the BigQuery table
data, but not your
BigQuery query stream.
And so you should
read the documentation
when you're on boarded
and consider these things
when you're making the
decision of what information
you want to octet as
part of this sets.
I'm now going to walk
through a demonstration that
talks about how you can set
up key access justifications,
and use it with some
of our partners.
Let's take a look at how I can
use a variety of External Key
Management tools to set block
and policy that uses key access
justifications.
Here I am using the
Thales tool to set
the set of allowed key
access justifications.
And now I'm going to try and
do the same thing with the tool
by Fortenix.
I'm also going to try
and do the same thing
using the Ionic tool,
which I'll continue
using for the rest of the
purposes of this demonstration.
As you can see, any partner that
supports the use of key access
justifications will allow you
to use these justifications
to gain access to
your keys based
on the inbound requests that
contain those justifications.
Let's go ahead and
use the example
of running a query
using BigQuery
with a table that's encrypted
by an externally managed key.
I press the Run button, and
the query is successful.
And when I go to my excel
key manager, I can see why.
The customer
initiated access value
was used to decrypt my table.
And because I've
allowed that value,
the query was successful.
Later on in the day I'm going to
go ahead and check my External
Key Manager again.
Here I can see that
a new decryption
request has been granted.
This time for Google
initiated system operation,
because BigQuery
needed to do this
in order to compress my data and
perform further optimizations.
Now if I were to
have an issue where
I needed to contact
Google support and Google
support needed to make
an access to my data,
they would need to
use this tool, which
validates the justification,
or validates the case
number that I've opened,
to see whether they
should have access.
When I go ahead and press
the send button here
you'll see that the
access gets denied.
If I go back to my
External Key Manager page,
I can see that a request was
made with customer initiated
support as the reason.
But because I'm
denying that value,
they were unable to
make that access.
I actually do need
to give them access
though, because I really
need them to check this out.
So I'm going to go
ahead and delete
that customer initiate support
value from the deny statement.
If the administrator tries
to make the access now again
using the same
support case number,
it would be validated
first on our side,
checking whether that
case is a real case,
and whether it's
open and assigned
to the person in question, and
whether the administrator has
the appropriate privileges.
But then it's also evaluated
again by the case manager,
and this time it's allowed.
And I can see the customer
initiated support here
in the values column,
So hopefully you've got
a better understanding
of how key access justifications
and External Key Manager
work together in practice to
make you the ultimate arbiter
of access to your data.
And why that's such
an important thing
to have when you're putting
very, very highly sensitive
information on the Cloud.
What are some of
the key takeaways
we want you to leave
with this presentation?
First of all is keep your data
in our cloud, not your keys.
You're going to get this
unprecedented level of control,
and keep possession
of your keys.
Use predictive data using
the External Key Manager
to store them outside of GCP.
We also have an upcoming
Cloud EKM white paper
that you should look out for.
It's going to talk about
some best practices on how
to architect the Cloud EKM
with GCP so that you can
take into account some of the
reliability concerns you might
have.
Then, if possible, you should
use key access justifications
to get you that extra amount
of granularity and visibility
over access to your data through
the use of these key access
policies.
And when you store your
keys outside of GCP,
you can set these policies
up to deny Google access
for whatever reason.
So you can continue
using your service
as you were beforehand, while
knowing that you're in control
and having the ability to
block Google for reasons
that you don't want.
We hope you've really gotten
a lot out this presentation
today.
We're extremely
excited to continue
talking to you about
these new products
as we continue to expand
our offerings in this space.
Thanks very much, and we look
forward to hearing from you
soon.
Bye now.